تذكرون فيلم ماتريكس وماذا حل بالبشر
عندما اصبحت الالات اكثر ذكاء
الامر لم يعد خيالا علميا فابرز مطوري
انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي
يطالب بتشكيل وكاله دوليه لحمايه البشر من
هذا الذكاء بعد ان اصبح اكثر ذكاء من
صانعي
[موسيقى]
بينما نتجه نحو الذكاء الاصطناعي العام
والتاثير الذي سيكون له وقوه تلك
التكنولوجيا اعتقد اننا بحاجه الى التعامل
مع ذلك بجديه مثل ما نتعامل مع تقنيات
اخرى قويه جدا وهذا هو المكان الذي اعتقد
فيه شخصيا اننا بحاجه الى مخطط شامل
بينما كان التمان يقدم افادته للكونجرس
الامريكي حول الذكاء الاصطناعي وجدت هذه
الشابه ضالتها العاطفيه نديما يشاركها
الاحساس والمشاعر وقد يلتقيان ويتبادلان
التجارب وفي الحقيقه انه وهم انه الذكاء
الاصطناعي الذي وصل حد التلاعب بمشاعر
البشر
كانت هذه القنبله اهم تحد لوجود البشر
لذلك اقيمت وكاله دوليه لمراقبه الانشطه
النوويه اليوم مبتكر الذكاء الاصطناعي
يحذرون من ان الخطر على الوجود قد يكون
كاملا في جهاز حاسوب او هاتف النقال لذلك
اصبحت الحاجه ماسه لتشكيل وكاله دوليه
لمراقبه الذكاء الاصطناعي وابتكاراته
خيرها وشرها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات